les changements climatiques si quoi tout
d'abord il faut savoir que l'effet de
serre est un phénomène d'origine
naturelle qui maintient la température
moyenne de la planète environ 15 degrés
celsius en retenant dans l'atmosphère
une partie de la chaleur qui nous
provient du soleil autrement notre
planète ne serait qu'une énorme boule de
glace à partir de 1850 avec
l'industrialisation les humains se sont
mis à libérer dans l'atmosphère des gaz
qui accentue cet effet de serre la
combustion du pétrole et du gaz naturel
la déforestation et l'agriculture
intensive produisent entre autres du
dioxyde de carbone du méthane et du
protoxyde d'azoté conséquence la chaleur
du soleil reste davantage emprisonnés
l'atmosphère se réchauffe
selon le calcul des scientifiques la
concentration des gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère est passé de 270
parties par million avant la révolution
industrielle à plus de 400 parties par
million aujourd'hui c'est l'accumulation
la plus importante en 800 milles 1 on
remarque déjà une hausse de la
température moyenne de l'atmosphère de
la planète de près de un degré celsius
ça veut dire des vagues de chaleur plus
longue et plus intense et plus de
phénomènes météorologiques extrêmes une
augmentation des précipitations dans
certaines régions des sécheresses dans
d'autres la fonte des glaces
continentales et le réchauffement des
océans provoquent une hausse du niveau
des mers menaçant d'engloutir des îles
et éventuellement des villes côtières
comme miami et new york
les océans absorbent aussi du co2 ce qui
cause leur acidification la vie marine
est perturbé et si on ne fait rien
la température du globe pourrait
augmenter de plus de 4 degrés d'ici la
fin du siècle un rythme trop rapide pour
que de nombreux animaux et plantes
puissent adapter
par exemple le taux de mortalité des
saumons sockeye augmente en colombie
britannique
en raison de la hausse des températures
de l'eau dans le fleuve fraser les
changements climatiques pourraient
entraîner une diminution des rendements
agricoles menaçant la sécurité
alimentaire de millions d'êtres humains
de larges populations devraient devoir
migrer changer de pays augmentant les
risques de conflits mais il ya des
solutions pour éviter le pire il faut
diminuer de manière importante
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
limiter la hausse des températures à 2
degrés celsius demandera une réduction
de ces gaz d'au moins 40% d'ici 2050 par
rapport aux émissions de 2006 et il
faudra les faire disparaître ou presque
d'ici 2100 il faudra considérablement
améliorer le rendement des énergies
renouvelables une tâche difficile mais
pas impossible
tout dépend de nyon